Okay,
is,
is a lousy,
but,
uh,
you know,
I'm old enough to have lived through a
few business cycles so I'm not
particularly perturbed about it by it.
And um,
you know,
I would say that I'm a change creates
opportunity.
So from an entrepreneur's perspective,
this isn't a good time or bad time,
it's just the time.
It's the time like any other time and
any other time,
uh,
there's always opportunities.
Now the opportunity has to fit with the,
the,
uh,
the current economic context.
Uh,
but I don't think the fact that the,
uh,
economies,
at a slow period and,
and,
and maybe so for awhile,
there shouldn't be anything.
The turtle
for sure.
Well,
uh,
you know,
I think just so many stupid things that
are currently going on,
there's a few things that would be
really helpful for small business.
I'm a huge and unmanageable costs for
small businesses,
healthcare and the cost to the
individual entrepreneur.
If you leave a corporate job and start
your own business,
even just to do,
to take care of yourself and your family
is a huge,
huge expense,
that's a problem.
That's not just for small businesses is
a national problem that we have a,
that the issue of healthcare that really
needs to be addressed and there's got to
be affordable healthcare for a to allow
people who work in small business to
have the coverage that they need.
And I would extend that to thinking
about all sorts of other employee
benefits and pensions and so on,
a great obstacle for small businesses to
be able to attract people out of
corporate jobs if they have to give up
some of those,
some of those perks of pensions and so
on.
Um,
uh,
so healthcare is one big issue at this.
The second big issue.
And uh,
we're now dealing with a gasoline that
at unheard of prices,
uh,
and um,
which is adding a real burden for lots
of folks just getting back and forth to
work.
But it's changing the nature of our
economy.
Uh,
this is potentially a good thing if a,
this can be signaled in some,
through some policy way to suggest that
we are going to for once take seriously
the idea of reducing our dependence on
oil and the venture community is just
chomping at the bit a to be able to
address some of these issues of
renewable energy.
Uh,
the problem is that as oil prices have
gone up and down,
a previous investments didn't pan out
because the oil price goes up and the
price comes down and all of a sudden the
cost of these old alternative
technologies,
uh,
is too expensive.
So,
uh,
I think,
something that could really be a great
boost to the economy is,
is a serious,
I'm serious policy,
a initiative to address the healthcare
costs and a serious policy issue,
uh,
to,
allow entrepreneurs to address the issue
of renewable energies.
And that will just bring so much a new
talent and ideas into the marketplace.